We just learned how to make the raddest eggplant parm.
And what's amazing is this cookbook is
about a sort of matriculation,
a choose-your-own-adventure, what you have left over
then becomes the next dish.
So we made eggplant parm.
We have some sauce lesto (stutters),
sauce left over, and Alexis is gonna show us
what we can turn that into.
Take it away.
So we've spent all this time making some amazing sauce,
and rather than let it go to waste,
I mean, you can save it for, you know,
freeze it for a later day, put it on pasta.
Pasta!
But we're gonna make some saucy eggs and tomatoes,
which just got simmered on the stove.
And you can actually, I think you can come help me.
If you actually wanna like dole this out into an even layer.
I'll dole it.
And this is such a quick, easy, amazing breakfast recipe.
So you can kind of like make four
divots.
Four divots.
And then if you'll actually help me just like crack-
Ooh!
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Um.
I'm.
Alexis.
(audience laughs)
Do you remember when I told you I was messy?
Okay, but I'm messy, too.
I think it was a
group effort.
Nope, it was,
I just like proving my point sometimes.
(laughs) I'm.
Messes are made in the kitchen, watch this.
Ooh!
Hey, there we go.
There we go!
(audience applauds)
Redemption!
Redemption.
And you know, I like to add some cheese,
you know, if you're making eggplant parm,
we've got some mozzarella left over,
and you can just kind of like add this.
(audience applauds)
That's it.
My cookbook is called "Rebel Homemaker."
(Alexis and audience laughs)
Which I wrote with an incredible chef Pilar Valdes.
I'm also mad, 'cause I screwed up that, oh, and, wait.
Well, okay, the joy of this
Nope, wait a minute.
is that we're not actually gonna eat this one,
'cause we have a done one right here.
Thank God!
This is what it's gonna look like, yeah!
(audience applauds)
The magic of television.
Right, I mean I like to add,
so I like to add some cheese, if you have it,
we're using mozzarella, you know, just something that gets
nice and melty, adds a little flavor element.
But you could also add spinach,
you can add really whatever you have in your pantry.
I love spinach in the morning.
So I would totally green this out.
But the pepper and the basil,
I swear, we can all be these beautiful platers
with garnish and thoughtfulness.
Plating is actually
my strong suit.
Plating, you just need
some herbs.
Yeah, garnish,
That's all it takes.
It changes everything.
I mean, how do you feel like-
(audience applauds)
Dipping.
Red dipped in just...
I feel real good about it is how I feel.
Oh my God!
God!
I mean, so that sauce is getting cooked again,
it's like more flavorful.
You've got the perfectly cooked eggs, serve it.
It changes the flavor profile, I love it.
Oh my God, I'm so excited that I got to do this with you.
(audience applauds)
Like all of my friends
in the culinary world
were freaking out that you were coming on this show.
That's really sweet, thank you.
So thank you.
And can we please do this again?
I hope so.
And can I be messy?
Me too.
Okay, good!
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much.
You know how they say, "Let's break bread?"
Yes.
We can break eggs.
(laughs) Perfect!
Perfect, all right, thank you, Alexis.
Grab your copy of "To the Last Bite,"
my new favorite cookbook available now
wherever books are sold.
(upbeat music)